hi everyone it's Joanna here today's
workout will be working on your arms as
well as your shoulders so what you'll
need are two pairs of dumbbells one pair
of lightweight dumbbells between two to
three kilos each and one pair of medium
weight dumbbells between five to six
kilos each so this workout is strength
base which is important for you to build
lean muscle mass and to tone up so let's
start lifting
[Music]
let's start with a quick warm-up to warm
up the arms and shoulders okay let's
start with small arm circles to begin
with
just to warm up our joints and now let's
make the circle bigger good
really feel the stretch on your arms as
well as your back
and now reverse it
Bring It Forward
big circles
you should start to feel your shoulders
warming up
smaller circles
and good now just shake it out okay grab
your light pair of dumbbells all right
so a little bit of shoulder Mobility
Place both dumbbells with the Palms
facing in and just drive it out
and drive it in so keep your arms and
elbows close to your body
this is just to work on your shoulder
Mobility good
and
remember Do not drop your dumbbells okay
so keep both arms in a 90 degree angle
and just drive the dumbbells out good
job and now just drop it back down let's
raise one dumbbell up at one time again
this is just your warm-up okay so go for
the lighter pair of dumbbells
up and down
and now let's go to the side one to the
side and one to the side
still warming up
I remember as you contract that's when
you want to breathe out okay remember
this throughout the entire workout
and one more and now just big shoulder
rolls
good job okay now drop your dumbbells
let's start with the heavier pair of
dumbbells so the first workout is going
to be a bicep curl to a shoulder press
so what I'm going to do is again keep
both elbows close to your body curl it
up and immediately press the dumbbells
straight up so this is going to work on
your biceps as well as your shoulders
are we ready let's go one up curl it up
and press it straight up remember to
keep your chest up keep your body
straight do not Arch your lower back
okay if you find yourself arching your
lower back and if you find yourself
struggling to press the dumbbell
straight up then go with a lighter pair
of dumbbells good up press
remember with strength training it's all
about controlled movement do not rush
through the workout curling up
press good job
right arms keep your elbows close to
your body
only the first exercise and I'm already
feeling the work so we want to repeat
the first round twice and now drop it
down okay
get down onto the mat no dumbbells let's
get into push-up with rotation still
working on your arms and your chest as
well as your shoulders are we ready give
me one strong push-up rotate to the left
and now one strong push up and rotate to
the right
so by alternating between dumbbells and
body weight this is going to really
challenge the upper body strength find
your balance
push up
rotate good job
and up if this is too much drop onto
your knees push up and small rotation
okay so choose your option
we're going to repeat
round one and the two exercises twice
up get back up onto your toes push
rotate and one solid push up good job
okay grab your dumbbells
same exercises bicep curl to show the
Press alright are we ready
keep your elbows close to your body curl
it up press it up
so there will be
five rounds in total and this is the
first
round of exercises up press it straight
up good job
pull it up press nice halfway there
who wants sexy arms then let's lift with
me good job
curl up press up
hoo
nice and torn arms let's go two more
remember do not swing your body okay up
press up and drop it back down all right
get onto the floor push up with rotation
choose your option either on your knees
or on your toes all right
remember to really start in a solid
plank position one push-up
rotate down push up
and rotate it
find your balance as you rotate
shift your body weight to one side
and in a way it's sort of like a short
break
for your arms
rotate good job
up
nice
come on give me at least two to three
more push-ups
twist
I guess we can fit in one more
twist
and drop it done all right
that is the end of the first round take
a shot 45 seconds break and we want to
move on to the second round so what you
can do is just
Shake Your Arms out and just stretch it
a little bit okay stretch it out good
Shake It Out
and stretch
oh
shoulder rolls
and forward
so it's going to be a full on 25 minutes
arms and shoulders workout at the end of
this workout I can promise you your
shoulders will be on fire alright so
grab your heavier pair of dumbbells the
next workout is going to be Arnold press
so place the dumbbells directly in front
of you with your palms facing in what
I'm going to do is lift one dumbbell
straight up rotate your wrist bring it
back down and straight up
so start with your palms facing in as
you rotate up the dumbbells your palms
should face out all right pressing up
and press it straight up good there you
go rotate and press
so this is going to really work on your
front as well as your side belts good
job
alternating between the left and right
press it up
rotate
and bring it back down
and good all right we are not dropping
the dumbbells still working on your
shoulders up right row so place the
dumbbells close to your hips
with your palms facing in all I want to
do is drive the dumbbell straight up
with the elbows pointed up bring it back
down
up
and down okay as you come up pause for
one second feel the work on your
shoulders and drive it back down there
you go up
and down remember Point your elbows out
drive the dumbbell close to your chest
breathe out as you bring it up
and breathe in
small controlled movement
to build
solid muscles good up
back down
up
and down one last one up
down and just shake it out a little bit
okay round two my shoulders are on fire
are we ready for our North press so
remember bring both dumbbells up with
the Palms facing in okay alternating
between left and right so drive it up
press it up
and press good job
nice and solid
press
there you go push it up
up nice
again same thing as you push the
dumbbells remember to breathe out
there you go
remember to rotate your wrist
rotate
really feel the work on your shoulders
up
maintain a slight Bend in your knees
okay so do not lock your knees if you
need to if it's getting too heavy use a
little bit of momentum just a little bit
one last one up and just drop it down
okay
final exercise
and this is the end of the second round
are we ready for upright row remember to
point your elbows out not this way if
you're doing this it's wrong Point your
elbows out good job okay drive it up and
down
up and down
as high as you can the dumbbells should
be just right under your chest control
down don't just let it drop okay up and
control the back down up control
The Eccentric movement is equally just
as important it will put your muscles
under more tension so up
one two up one two there you go up and
really fight against gravity
control it back down good
one two last one more
and now good news drop the dumbbells oh
my gosh my arms are on fire okay
okay so take a short 45 seconds break if
you need to grab some water and keep
yourself hydrated for the next round the
third round we want to lie down onto the
mat again we're still using the heavier
pair of dumbbells this is going to be a
tricep press so lie flat down onto the
mat
okay place your heels close to your butt
keep your elbows Once More close to your
body and keep the dumbbells close
together with your palms facing in all I
want you to do is press the dumbbell
straight up drive it back down
and up okay so remember keep your elbows
close to your body
with the Palms facing in this will work
on your tricep if you're doing it this
way this is going to work on your chest
so keep the dumbbell straight Palms face
in elbows tight and press up
straight up
feel the work on your triceps
and up good job so for this round we are
focusing on your triceps no more Bingo
wings okay let's Tone It Up Up back down
up and down gently tap onto the floor do
not rest your arms onto the floor just
tap and drop it down okay now push
yourself back up and we want to do
tricep push-ups okay this is going to be
more challenging again with triceps what
you want to do is always keep your
elbows close to you and pointed back so
let's start on your knees
keeping your elbows close yourself down
and push yourself up okay remember your
elbows should be pointing back down
control and up so this is going to be
working on your triceps not your chest
control it down
drive your chest close to the floor and
as you push up use the strength from
your triceps
good nice and controlled
up if this is too much take a short
break
and
join me when you're ready up
up down
up one more down
up
I guess you know the drill grab your
dumbbells and let's get back down onto
the mat
tricep press
oh
let's go remember keep your elbows close
to you bring the dumbbells up control
the back down
push it up okay
don't rest your arms
it's just for you to gently tap and push
it straight up
both puns facing in
if you want to count one two three and
up good job there you go
so all the tension
should be on your triceps down
up
back down
and up
few more
give me two more okay come on ladies up
one more
up
and slowly drop the dumbbells okay
oh my gosh tricep push-ups all right
it's challenging but I love this push-up
so remember start by having your pumps
directly under your shoulders Point your
elbows back push it down up push it back
up okay so drive your chest down towards
the floor remember that your body should
be moving down as one unit so if you're
doing this this is wrong okay
drive your butt down
chest down and push your entire body up
there you go back down and up I know
it's burning my arms are shaking
I can feel your pain up plus
two more okay up
up last one more come on
oh give me one more let's go
and Shake It Out okay so now let's get
Back Up
all right
shot break 45 seconds break Shake Your
Arms out if you need to give your tricep
a short break stretch it out a little
bit
all right hold it right there stretch
your triceps out and change to the other
side
and guess what for round four and five
we're going for the lighter pair of
dumbbells okay good news so grab your
lighter pair of dumbbells either two or
three kilos each or even one kilo if
you're a beginner so the next workout is
going to be a tricep Kickback so what
I'm going to do is hinge your hips
slightly again keep your elbows close to
your body and all I want you to do is
pick the dumbbells back so it's like a
kickback okay
as you kick the dumbbells up holy for
two counts one two view the squeeze on
your triceps and drive it back down
good so remember the movement is only
from your forearms not the entire arm so
you should not be doing this this is
wrong okay elbows close to your body
keep your elbows pointed back moving
only from your forearms kick it back
squeeze your tricep and bring it back
down squeeze good
one two pause
one more
and good job okay shake it out a little
bit
now we're moving on to reverse fly this
will work on your traps as well as your
red out so once more hinge slightly from
your hips and what I'm going to do is
face both Palms in and drive the
dumbbells up and out so it's like a
flying motion
but in a reverse position okay so
remember
from the side view you want to drive the
dumbbells up
and out so this should work on your red
delt you should feel
the top of your shoulders and the back
part working
remember hold it and bring it back down
it's going to be a little bit more
challenging and that's why we're lifting
lighter
up and down okay reverse position up and
down
bend your knees hinge your butt back and
down there you have it all right and
that's why we're lifting lighter because
there are small muscle groups which
still need to be worked on okay now
going back to tricep Kickback hinge
elbows tucked and ready take it back
controlled
back and controlled good job
and controlled
don't just drop the dumbbells
I want to see controlled movement up and
down
kick it back and down
feel the squeeze on your triceps squeeze
good squeeze right at the top hold it
come on ladies
we gotta work strong
for that toned arms
take it back
let's build some lean muscle mass let's
go two more one
last one more control two and drop it
back down okay reverse fly position
remember to hinge
your hips back again keep your knees
slightly bent Palms facing in dumbbells
directly in front of you gaze onto the
floor and now open it up
fly
your wings keep your elbows slightly
bent
all right
your arms should not be in a locked
position so keep your elbows slightly
bent and as you lift it up squeeze the
back of your shoulders squeeze good job
squeeze
there you go all right from the front
view
up and down so squeeze
good job
looking strong
again control it down don't just drop it
when you're tired control it back down
control
and control good job all right now drop
your dumbbells for a little while we are
done with four rounds one final round
okay shake it out a little bit one final
round and we are still going for the
lighter weights we're going to work on
your shoulders and your arms as well all
right
oh I know I know it's hard work 25
minutes just on your arms and shoulders
but I promise you it'll be worth it so
grab your dumbbells the next workout is
going to be a lateral raise to a front
raise so this is what it's going to look
like again remember to keep your elbows
slightly bent so lateral raise opening
up to the side front raise the elbow to
the front and to the dumbbells to the
front all right let's go to the side and
both dumbbells to the front remember to
keep a slight Bend in your knees so
don't stand too straight okay keep a
slight Bend up to the side good and
front
so just like the workout
the exercise name we're working on your
side delt this is a side dealt and your
your front delt okay side
and front if it's getting too heavy just
a little bit of momentum
just a little bit okay not too much
don't swing your body if you're doing
this this is wrong just a little bit one
more
and drop it back down all right
this next exercise is going to be just
your body weight up down plank I'm sure
a lot of you are familiar with this
workout so let's start in a low plank
position okay it's going to really
challenge your your shoulders and your
arms push yourself up
and back down
and change the other arm
left up
okay and now right good job remember
minimal movement from your hips it's all
about bracing your core it's all about
using the strength from your arms to
push your body
up
there you go
nice solid planks
up
a few more
it's getting tough
but we're not stopping right now
down
and up
and good job
let's grab
your dumbbells
okay are we ready for the final round
this is your final round all right
lateral raise to front raise bend your
elbows up lateral and front remember
that your dumbbells should not be higher
than your shoulders okay so lift it up
and front good job
remember it should just be a slight
momentum don't
swing your body forward and back front
sight
front
sight
and front
give me three more okay one
two
oh my gosh it's burning
three last one more
and drop it back down no more dumbbells
let's go final up down plank to finish
off this
exercise oh are we ready
let's get into a plank position
push yourself up
and control it back down
up
push good job
you have worked this hard this is your
final 30 seconds
so stay with me
stay with me to the Finishing Line okay
remember do not sway your hips too much
control brace your core
back down
push yourself up
everything is on fire right now not just
my arms my entire body
up
down
up
that's one more
oh my gosh
all right now let's slowly get back up
my arms my shoulders
everything is on fire right now so let's
and this workout with a quick stretch
okay
just big
shoulder rolls
back
and now forward
you have worked so hard
and this is really an amazing workout
and I would encourage you to repeat it
at least two times a week okay we should
work on our upper bodies I know most
ladies tend to avoid upper body days
because it is more difficult all right
shake it out let's just stretch your
shoulders
one arm across
and hold it
release
and now the other side
and just hold it right there
[Music]
chop breathe into your stretch release
again tricep stretch drive your left
hand back
pull towards your elbow
and really feel the stretch along your
triceps
all right
good job remember to stand tall
and now let's change the other side
and just slowly bring your heart rate
back down as well
and now just
pops your hands together your palms
together and just Arch slightly and pull
yourself forward
okay
really feel the stretch on your upper
back
job
and now in a reverse position
hands back
pull and Arch look towards the ceiling
and now let's just take three deep
breaths to end this workout breathe in
and out
once more breathe in
breathe in all the good energy
and out
and one final breath
breathe in
release amazing amazing job well done
that was a solid 25 minutes of arms and
shoulders workouts do combine this upper
body workout with my lower body workout
on my YouTube channel as well if you
haven't yet subscribed to my YouTube
channel then what are you doing go ahead
and hit the Subscribe Button as I will
be sharing a lot more workout videos
recipe videos as well as mindset tips
and don't forget to let me know how you
got on in this workout let me know in
the comments below and I will see you in
my next video all the best